[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installments of harry
potter theory
in this video i'm going to be discussing
and breaking down
the differences between the fateful duel
between voldemort and dumbledore
inside the ministry atrium this jewel
happened
in the order of the phoenix and it's
arguably the most impressive looking
jewel on screen
that we've seen to date it was a jewel
of epic proportions
good against evil light against dark and
it totally overshadowed all of the
boring stalemates that harry had
with voldemort however one thing that is
completely worth mentioning
is that their jewel was represented very
differently from book to film
the film adaptation certainly took some
liberties with the contents of the book
and rather than staying true to the
picture the book had initially painted
for us
it mixed things up most likely for
increased cinematic
and dramatic effect but in doing so
they actually portrayed the characters
in a very different light than we had
expected
and it was honestly quite inconsistent
with what we had initially read
in the books in the book their skirmish
of course breaks out
when a helpless harry who's in mortal
danger is saved by
dumbledore who arrives just in the nick
of time i have nothing more to say to
you
potter he said quietly you have irked me
too often
for too long avada kadavra harry had not
even opened his mouth to resist
his mind was blank his wand pointing
uselessly at the floor
but the headless golden statue of the
wizard in the fountain had sprung alive
leaping from its plinth to land with a
crash on the floor between harry and
voldemort
the spell merely glanced off its chest
as the statue flung out its arms to
protect harry
what cried voldemort staring around and
then he breathed
dumbledore voldemort raised his wand and
another jet of green lights streaked at
dumbledore
who turned and was gone in a whirling of
his cloak next second
he had reappeared behind voldemort and
waved his one toward the remnants of the
fountain
the other statue sprang to life the
statue of the witch ran at bellatrix
who screamed and sent spells streaming
uselessly off its chest
before it dived at her pinning her to
the floor meanwhile the goblin and the
house elf
scuttled towards the fireplaces set
along the wall
and the one-armed centaur galloped to
voldemort who vanished and reappeared
beside the pool
the headless statue thrust harry
backwards away from the fight
as dumbledore advanced on voldemort and
the golden centaur cantered around them
both
in the film however this part is
completely taken out
dumbledore simply shows up using the flu
network and walks toward voldemort
he then says to voldemort it was foolish
to come here tonight tom
the auras are on their way by which time
i should be gone
and you will be dead and those lines are
actually consistent from book to film
these are also the lines that indicate
the proper beginning to their jewel
each man immensely confident that they
will be the one to overpower the other
back to the book dumbledore flicked his
own wand the force of the spell that
emanated from it
was such that harry though shielded by
his golden guard
felt his hair stand on end as it passed
and this time
voldemort was forced to conjure a
shining silver shield out of thin air to
deflect it
the spell whatever it was caused no
visible damage to the shield
though a deep gong-like note
reverberated from it
an oddly chilling sound you do not seek
to kill me
dumbledore called voldemort his scarlet
eyes narrowed over the top of the shield
above such brutality are you we both
know that there are other ways of
destroying a man
tom dumbledore said calmly continuing to
walk towards voldemort
as though he had not a fear in the world
as though nothing had happened to
interrupt his stroll up the hall
merely taking your life would not
satisfy me i admit
there is nothing worse than death
dumbledore snyd voldemort
you are quite wrong said dumbledore
still closing in upon voldemort and
speaking as lightly as though they were
discussing the mata over drinks
harry felt scared to see him walking
along undefended and shieldless
he wanted to cry out a warning but his
headless guard kept shunting him
backwards towards the wall
blocking his every attempt to get out
from behind it indeed
your failure to understand there are
things much worse than death
has always been your greatest weakness
in the film however
dumbledore and voldemort instantly enter
into a magical power struggle
with one flick of their ones
dumbledore's red jet of light met
voldemort's green jet in mid-air
and the two held their ground as sparks
flew and the room began to fall to
pieces
unable to contain the sheer magical
power being produced the pair appeared
to be completely evenly matched
there isn't much talking like in the
book and i think this is a particularly
important piece that they left out
as i think their discussion reveals to
us just how powerful dumbledore truly is
throughout their jewel the books
continuously describe dumbledore's
nonchalant attitude toward everything
going on
here he is faced head to head with one
of the darkest and most powerful wizards
of all time but he's so calm
there are a few lines from the above
passage that suggest to me
a dumb model is not even remotely
worried about losing when he walks
towards voldemort
it's constantly reinforced that he's
calm and that he
had not a fear in the world dumbledore's
demeanor toward voldemort during their
jewel
was even described as though they were
discussing the matter over drinks
i think that one of the reasons the
films left this out was because
one-sided battles aren't fun
dumbledore at least as far as the books
are concerned is by far the most
powerful wizard of all time
not only was he magically talented but
he also possessed the elder wand during
their duel
if we had to go by strictly the books
voldemort was completely outmatched
however this wouldn't have been as
visually interesting on screen
and showing a voldemort in such a
vulnerable state really takes away from
his character
he's supposed to be this dark presence
the dark lord
a fear-inspiring figure that no one is
safe from but that doesn't work when one
of the main characters on the
protagonist's side
walks toward him like he's having a
picnic so in that respect
i sort of understand why they omitted
that portion of the text from this scene
however i'm not sure they should have
eliminated the dialogue completely
which they did back to the book another
jet of green light flew from behind the
silver shield
this time it was a one-armed centaur
galloping in front of dumbledore
that took the blast and shattered into a
hundred pieces but before the fragments
had even hit the floor
dumbledore had drawn back his wind and
waved it as though brandishing a whip
a long thin flame flew from the tip it
wrapped itself around voldemort
shield and all for a moment it seemed
dumbledore had won
but then the fiery rope became a serpent
which relinquished its hold on voldemort
at once
and turned hitting furiously to face
dumbledore
once again this massively differs from
what we saw in the film
first of all there were no statues being
manipulated in the film version of their
jewel
not in any way shape or form next
dumbledore never seems to use any sort
of
fiery whip like spell on voldemort the
only part of this that does match the
film
is the fiery serpent which does attack
dumbledore
and was voldemort's doing look out harry
yelled
but even as he shouted another jet of
green light flew a dumbledore
from voldemort's wand and the snake
struck fork swooped down in front of
dumbledore
opened his beak wide and swallowed the
jet of green light whole
he burst into flame and fell to the
floor small wrinkled
and flightless at the same moment
dumbledore brandished his wand
in one long fluid movement the snake
which had been an instant from sinking
its fangs into him
flew high into the air and vanished in a
wisp of dark smoke
and the water in the pool rose up and
covered voldemort like a cocoon of
molten glass
this part is particularly interesting
because it actually seems to paint
dumbledore
in a little bit more of a vulnerable
state and i think that it suggests that
dumbledore was perhaps too confident at
the beginning of the duel
in the film adaptation at no point does
dumbledore need fawkes to show up
and save him from one of voldemort's
attacks but what the text shows us is
that had fork's not been there
dumbledore would have either been hit
with vada kadavra
or the fiery snake spell as both were
being directed at him
at once i feel that this is of
particular importance
as it may even indicate that dumbledore
was a loser of their jewel
forks blocked a spell from hitting him
and unless dumbledore really didn't need
forks to do that
it suggests that he may have been the
loser it's curious the film adaptation
would have left this out
but once again i think they may have
intentionally showcased voldemort and
dumbledore
on fairly equal ground after this
happens the end of the jewel in both the
book and film
is fairly anticlimactic in the book for
a few seconds
voldemort was visible only as a dark
rippling faceless figure
shimmering and indistinct upon the
plinth clearly struggling to throw off
the suffocating mass
then he was gone and the water fell with
a crash back into its pool
slopping wildly over the sides drenching
the polished floor
and in the film after dumbledore defends
against voldemort's barrage of glass
being flung toward him
voldemort simply disappears and
possesses harry so
as we can see this jewel is massively
different from book to film
and i feel that the major differences
can be summed up as follows
number one dialogue there is a distinct
lack of dialogue in the film adaptation
of their jewel
and it deprives the viewer the sense of
confidence that dumbledore felt
when entering the duel number two avada
kadavra and the statues
in the books damodal is blocking
voldemort's constant barrage of killing
curse attacks
by using statues however in the film
adaptation
dumbledore seems to be defending against
voldemort's killing curse with his own
jet of red light
which contradicts everything that we
know about the spell the killing curse
is supposedly unblockable and harry can
only defend against it using
expelliarmus
because of special circumstances so the
fact that dumbledore is simply using
whatever magic he wants
to defend against it doesn't actually
make a lot of sense
number three dumbledore being saved as
we saw above
dumbledore ends up being saved by forks
in the book this doesn't happen at all
in the film
and it's interesting they'd leave this
out as it may have actually meant that
dumbledore was a loser
that is if he needed forks to bail him
out maybe he didn't
number four dumbledore's demeanor in the
film domital is sort of painted as a bit
weak
frail and old when entering into the
jewel this couldn't be further from the
truth
as we can clearly see in the dialogue
from the text the dumbledore was very
strong
and confident and that about sums it up
which version
do you prefer let me know in the comment
section
below until next time remember
time will not slow down when something
unpleasant lies ahead
you